bei sonnenstürmen wird aus der
sonnenatmosphäre eine gigantische wolke
aus unvorstellbar heißem gas
herausgeschleudert die dabei
ausgestoßenen teilchen protonen können
im weltall geschwindigkeiten von
mehreren millionen stundenkilometern
erreichen und es gibt noch weitere
spannende text zum thema sonnensturm wie
gefährlich können sonnenstürme der erde
wirklich werden und inwieweit sind wir
vorbereitet können die teilchen auch die
hülle eines raumschiffes durchdringend
die fünf spannenden effekt über
sonnenstürme bekommt er jetzt bei pixum
science fiction viel spaß dabei und
herzlich willkommen abonniert den kanal
um kein video mehr zu verpassen
[Musik]
der heftigsten sonnensturm fand 1859
statt der sonnensturm 1859 ging
tatsächlich in die geschichte ein
innerhalb von knapp einer woche ende
august anfang september passierten
mehrere starke sonneneruptionen
hintereinander
die ausgestoßene materie erreichte nach
etwa 17 stunden die erde und hatte eine
geschwindigkeit von mehr als 2000
stundenkilometern darauf die
polarlichter konnten selbst in rom
hawaii und havanna beobachtet werden
stark ströme zerstörten telegrafen
leitungen und das gesamte netz wurde
enorm beschädigt dabei war es gerade
erst installiert worden
dieser mega sonnensturm wird übrigens
als das pairing mehrheitlich bezeichnet
auch die iss ist nicht wirklich sicher
erst im vergangenen september musste die
iss besatzung wegen eines gigantischen
protonen stumpf schnell in deckung gehen
am vierten september 2017 hatte die
jüngste serie mit schwachen ausbrüchen
begonnen zwei tage später folgte dann
eine der stärksten eruption der letzten
fünf jahre und gleichzeitig eine der
fünf heftigsten die geht auf der sonne
beobachtet worden waren daraufhin folgte
dann einen sonnen beben von
forschungsteams auch koronaler
massenauswurf genannt solch einer
eruption hat die energie von mehreren
milliarden atombombenexplosion jetzt
konnten forschungsteams auch
herausfinden wo der ausgangspunkt für
die eruption serie liegt und zwar am
rand der sichtbaren sonnenscheibe der
sich von der erde wegdrehte die
besatzung auf der iss bekam dann am
zehnten september tatsächlich den befehl
alert also alarm
daraufhin musste
die besatzung einige zeit in einem
schutzraum ausharren
zudem bekamen sie die anweisung weniger
geschützte bereiche der raumstation
aufgrund der starken strahlung zu meiden
roskosmos die russische raumfahrtagentur
betont trotz allem dass das alles eine
reine vorsichtsmaßnahme gewesen sei
denn die internationale raumstation iss
sehr sicher konstruiert fest steht aber
auch ein teilchen schaumkanone den
großteil der schützende wirkung der
erdatmosphäre tatsächlich gravierend
sein
polarlichter sind die schönen seiten der
sonnenstürme ja ihr habt alle sehr schon
mal fotos vom polarlicht angesehen oder
sogar in echt sie sind tatsächlich die
schönen seiten der sonnenstürme denn
durch den eintritt der plasmawolke in
das irdische magnetfeld werden
elektrische spannung in der atmosphäre
hervorrufen elektrisch geladene teilchen
werden beschleunigt und dringen parallel
zu den feldlinien des erdmagnetfeldes
tiefer in die erdatmosphäre ein
wenn sie dort auf das düstere atmosphäre
gas treffen regen sie einzelne gas
zeichen zum leuchten
wenn sehr starke sonnenstürme das
erdmagnetfeld enorm verformen kann man
polarlichter dann auch in deutschland
sehen und auf der 2 sonnenstürme sind
kaum vorauszusagen sonderaktion formen
plasmawolken und dadurch entstehen
magnetische stürme in unserer
erdatmosphäre das problem solche
ausbrüche sind nicht wirklich
vorauszusehen doch die signale einer
sonneneruption erreichen die erde
innerhalb von acht minuten
forschungsteams weltweit sind überzeugt
davon dass uns eine solche teilchen flut
sehr gefährlich werden kann
das hat mir gerade schon gehört und
dafür sind wir sehr schlecht auf einen
möglichen nächsten sonnensturm
vorbereitet forschungsteams weltweit
versuchen also notgedrungen über
statistiken herauszukristallisieren wie
häufig und wie schlimm sonnenstürme uns
in der erdgeschichte bereits getroffen
haben die radioaktivität im baumringen
liegt zb den hinweis nahe dass im jahr
775 eine gigantische teilchen welle über
die erde hinweg gefegt ist auch die
analyse des lichts von knapp 150 tausend
sonnen
den sternen konnte der wissenschaftswelt
etwas über die häufigkeit solcher stürme
verraten
demnach könnten ähnlich heftige
sonneneruption wm jahr 775 etwa alle
2000 jahre auftreten noch in europa gibt
es kaum aufmerksamkeit von seiten der
politik anders dagegen in den usa da der
kongress schon 2015 einen aktionsplan
zum weltraumwetter verabschiedet
notfallpläne sollen entwickelt werden
und das stromnetz muss besser gegen
sonnenstürme abgeschirmt werden zwar
sähen teleskope und erdnahe satelliten
den ausbruch der sonne doch dann muss
auch eingeschätzt werden wie stark er
ausfallen wird und ob er die erde
überhaupt treffen wird erst 20 minuten
bevor der sturm die erde erreicht ist
dann auch klar in welche richtung sein
magnetfeld zeigen wird und das ist
entscheidend dafür wie gut er das
irdische magnetfeld durchdringen wird
derzeit spielen wir quasi russisches
roulette mit der sonne wichtig wäre also
die prozesse auf der sonne besser zu
verstehen um sie dann irgendwann einmal
auch vorher zu sagen zu können
der europäische solar bitter der anfang
2020 aufbrechen soll könnte dazu enorm
beitragen und der letzte fact nummer
eins gewaltige sonnenstürme bedrohen uns
menschen permanent sicher ist
sonneneruptionen können auch der erde
und uns menschen sehr gefährlich werden
selbst wenn der abstand zwischen sonne
und erde 150 millionen kilometer beträgt
und uns auch die erdatmosphäre einen
gewissen schutz bietet denn
sonneneruption formen plasmawolken und
dadurch entstehen magnetische stürme in
unserer erdatmosphäre
dann bringt röntgenstrahlung in die eu
wäre ein und verändert die eigenschaften
so dass funkwellen sich nicht mehr
ausbreiten können vor allem kurz und
ultra kurzwellen sind betroffen dort
findet vor allem der amateur und
mobilfunk stadt auch gps also das global
positioning system war von dem
sonnenschirm im vergangenen herbst
betroffenen sonnenstürme können aber
auch fatale folgen für die
stromversorgung auf der erde haben denn
riesige transformatoren könnten dann
gegrillt werden also zerstört werden die
meisten von uns würden dann erst einmal
im dunkeln sitzen und es gibt weitere
indirekte konsequenzen die ein starker
sonnensturm mit sich bringt ein
forschungsteam aus den usa hat
beispielsweise ermittelt dass bis zu
zwei drittel aller amerikaner durch
einen starken sonnenstürmen vom strom
und telekommunikationsnetz abgetrennt
werden können
der schaden für die wirtschaft und
infrastruktur wäre enorm und beträgt den
schätzungen zufolge acht bis gut 40
milliarden us dollar täglich
es gibt auch einige wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler die die sonnen
aufbrüche mit naturkatastrophen hier auf
der erde in verbindung bringen taifune
erdbeben und auch solche hurricanes wie
harvey und irma könnten indirekt folgen
von sonneneruptionen sein klingt logisch
wenn man bedenkt welch eine starke
energiequelle die sonne darstellt
eruptionen sind nach ansicht einiger
forschungsteams zwar nicht der direkte
auslöser solcher naturkatastrophen soll
setzt kleine störungen der
sonnenaktivität könnten lokale
wetterbedingungen demnach verstärken
dieses war übrigens eine video premiere
auf dem englischen kanal wenn er dort
nichts verpassen wollt dann abonniert
ihn hier und da drunter geht es weiter
mit ice age in europe vulva gulfstream
campus tänze bis dann also ich freue
mich auf euch auf dem englischen kanal
also nicht bis da sondern stay tuned zu
tun